>> THANK.INYE
LEADERS REMARKSPE
T ID.VE I
OROF TVIEN MEMBE
SA IN WHIC WICAL
IN THE UNITED STATES OERICA CANO
SOATAB ATION ABE
THABIS W
ARE WILLG EP
AT WE DDOES NOT MATTEG REPREST.
A LACK O
W THIS DENIASMUNNDNV A CERTAIN D
MATTER. SO LONG CLAIM IS AWE
UR ACTIONSVERY DAY AER
THAT IE IT ER
MAERE ISN OUR SED  L,  WNC
DEPICTIONS AGAINURLLGU TOS COTR.
IT IS ABOU  THEY MUS OF INDEPENF
AICOUT,S MED INOG
MABEEVDO YOU FIN DOES ANNE I
TH CHAMBER
WOULD YOF  WOU ALLOW THIS
NKSHOULDAP
ON A SCHOO IA ?
E DOUBLECAER ROS TALHORE
F  DIFFERENT THINGS,
WHS THE SGRESSIOIN AITH T OUTI
YOU H SON>>HE OHE TTH IONLLE E
THES TAKE
OUR AT THI A
WL DEFEND ONE
B THE OF BE  O
HAS AHEA
IET THIS
HAVIOR ACCEPTED,
THEN VOTAT SE.
OT DEFATGOSA.T I AM A RECENCTOL
TO RUN MS CAR.EN IMMRC
F CO ANYWHERE,ANYTIME FETH, THE
SHOULD CONTACT THE POLICE. TIS O
STAT MEMBER OF  INCITING  DEPICG
MEMBONH SIDE THE
S AVDE.T AS THE RANKING MR OF T
R FOR THND YEAR, T
ADDRESS AN DRESSE ETH WHICH  NOF
YESTERDAY AFTERNOOTHTY
PARTY DRAFTED THISN
HAVE THE TIME TOERVE  ETHICSOMM.
HAVE HADORORMATIMMS SHOULD
WHETR D WHO ARE TO MOVE   -- MAI
FOAR
THE CHAIRMAN CLATO HTOCHEDULGEET
ST RECORD, THIS LAST NIGHT.
COMMITTEETCED,N THE MEETINWAE CS
REESO
FOTE.
IF
CONFLICT OR EXCUSE WHY WE E
MAJORITY.HIN WAS A CONFLICT
SO HERE WE ARE TODAY
ON CHEY.EMOVED FROE FROM HCOD CT
COMMITTEES BY THEIN PARTY.
AJITY
MEMOVING TECD REPUBLICAN
THEIR MM.T SAGAN, MEMBERS ON IDO
VOO THE TODAY ANT NYF USAD